ein neuer blog und die sind gerade
unterwegs per deutschland ganz kurz vor
den gefahren und zwar nach worten die
gab's nächsten treffen mit niemand
geringerem als kaufland also liebe ist
echt super gerne bei kaufland einkaufen
viele von euch folgt uns auch um
instagram und dann wisst ihr natürlich
auch schon das erste zwei jahren immer
mal wirklich kaufen wenn ich liebe es
einfach da einkaufen zu gehen wir auch
mal gern die zeit ist für samstag an
beschäftigung mit seiner hansa hier geht
es aber kaum land zu kaufland ist
einfach so am herzen
zusammenarbeit sein ich mir so ein
herten zu kooperationen dass man
kooperation ich finde
zusammenarbeit trägt das erfülle sie
sonst in eine neutrale gläser und so
seht ihr einfach die produkte die ich
natürlich auch so immer bei kauf und
einen kopf
für mich ändert sich da gar nicht nur
dass ich hier von mir aus und ist in den
kontakt zu kaufland erhalten habe und
wir uns jetzt mal so von gesichts zu
durchgesehen spielen lernen und darauf
freue ich mich schon so lange wir machen
einen zwischenstopp in frankfurt liebe
frankfurt wird ist so eine punktestand
und ich weiß auch dass viele von euch
aus frankfurt kommen ihr könnt mir gerne
mal hier unten in die kommentare
schreiben
woher kommt christoph instagram schon
fragt von zwei tagen
und unglaublich über ganz deutschland
verteilten statistik kommen die meisten
aus berlin aber es ist gar nicht so also
ganz deutschland wir haben alles dabei
immer dieser strecke war die tür
aufmacht wenn man sich ganz frisch die
hände gewaschen hat schon jetzt auch
autofahrt spiel das gibt nämlich so wenn
man verschiedene kategorien und dann
sagte mir eine alte kategorie berufe
dann sage ich klempner und haben sie
muss dann einen briten ersten hansa
richter und zwar ins ende gemeint ist
und er sich kann gespeicherte chor im
ofen macht keinen spass gespielt ihre
marken
ich trage den ring noch eigentlich
kittmann ramseier und jetzt erwarten
euch gerne auch merz der autobahn und
hinterlieger musik im 3
[Musik]
die bremer in letzter zeit wie sie von
manager der französischen so cool ich
hätte sich mal hier und in der linken
wird dass ich zeigen eine rezession
hallo
durch den wochen bis zum 1
oh mein gott ich bin also um ehrlich zu
sein jetzt wurde laut dass man kompass
urlaub nennen kann ist sechs jahre her
natürlich wenn man mal in der türkei bei
der familie und einsetzen
ich war bei dem ich mein bruder meine
füße hochlegen
wenn man so einen traurigen traurigen
film rain man bei dir
das klingt traurig oder das ist traurig
hätten so normal geworden ist dann
wirklich ein bis zweimal im jahr urlaub
machen was ist schon normal
die prioritäten anders
und falls euch fragt wohin die flitzer
von total in der türkei
[Musik]
frankfurt in der innenstadt an der zeit
alle sind von der zeit sein das will ich
auch mal dagewesen sein leben war
frankfurt so eine geile stadt hören
aber trotzdem hier nicht leben können
sind zu viele rechte
das ist angriff formal wird findet uns
haben so viele leute erkannt einfach
silber über youtube als heute du musst
ja auch vorstellen solche erkennen ich
hab dich ja komischerweise also es
stimmt wirklich gerade kam eine ganze
jetzt ich habe den haben sie erkennen
sowohl von der seite
ich bin beim ring beim diamant ich noch
so zu haben so lassen von kein laden
gehen in diesen wochen auch gibt und wo
waren wir aber ich bin nicht so der
shopping typ aber ich habe da irgendeine
mache also doch sah eigentlich recht
günstig
so hier könnte ich jetzt nicht einfach
so im vorbeigehen unbedingt ausprobieren
jetzt haben uns genommen einfach so die
haben
makarov neuer als butt bloggerin muss
ich aber sagen dass ich mein drittes
auch online nach gelegentlich in die
infobox
man merkte es selbst gemacht sind ich
habe ist das ist verständlich dass man
gegenwärtig von einer neu trier also auf
eure empfehlungen sind sie jetzt bei
mama vorne und probiert habe ich noch
nicht aber schon mal sehr gut aus
ich stimme dir ist immer die reste immer
kurz bevor ich gegessen habe
er ist sagt haben wir haben sie
natürlich damit zu weniger ist ich
glaube angesagt ich hasse es ich hasse
es wenn du in dem bis ich hasse ist bei
maximaler merkte man ihre hand in hand
wenn man hier und da weiß man wenn man
ja die frau einkaufen war schon
[Musik]
ich bin schockiert
eine buchung teil höchstens ein euro
stück zum verständnis warum diese show
gibt den wifi stunden bei 60 euro
beinhalte zwar nicht alle habt ihr sind
nicht alle kennt ihr das nach dem essen
wenn man noch so ein absacker brauch in
form von latte macchiato bis ihr müsst
verstehen für mich ist latte macchiato
immer latte macchiato gewesen sagt sonja
anders etabliert wie im kopf das witzige
ist meine eltern hatten einen kaffee
junge für 18 jahre lang immer
ausgeholfen auch schon als kleinkind
quasi und ich habe in meiner thema cher
torge sagt immer ich habe sogar die
kunden haben es mir falsch beigebracht
wunderwaffe willkommen mach dich bereit
mit der ducati kinderbeauftragte danke
bitte schön
der beifahrer der park auftrag die seit
der antike beauftragte sondern weil wir
den besitzer von hunden waffe in essen
und in frankfurt kennen gehen natürlich
super gerne unseren latte macchiato
trinken und das coole ist haben sie hat
gerade mit ihm telefoniert
aber jetzt gehen wir erstmal reinkommen
[Musik]
manchmal ist auch engines in köln und
frankfurt
was meinst du
josef anfang
nach der tat bestimmt nicht der wein
truppe kann's noch mal
[Musik]
sind sie also bitte ich will keine
ermahnen nachrichten in den kommentaren
wünsche ich mir einfach gewesen
[Musik]
ihr habt ein neues gehört so ein cooler
chef und das könnt ihr gewinnen zweimal
zwei voll beladene waffeln und dann
könnte einfach mit meinem liebsten
kommen oder euren liebsten überraschung
machen wenn die gewonnen hat und dass
euch schmecken das was sie dafür tun
müssen genau ich habe ich aber alles
weitere noch einmal in die infobox
jetzt darf niemals fotos machen also und
so wirkte doch sehr überraschend
plötzlich ein gewinnspiel gestartet auch
sehr cool oder flüssigkeiten
ich habe angst
ein kredit auf dem weg nach stuttgart in
stuttgart familie und da sind wir immer
gerne wenn wir in baden württemberg zu
tun haben und natürlich auch moose zu
besuchen aber wir bekommen dann
schlafplatz und die verdauung um die
zwei stunden
wer fährt der hansa
[Musik]
wir sind in heilbronn haben gleich
unseren termin irgendwohin also ist mir
so viele städte miteinander verzweigt
dass man einfach nur noch ein bullshit
entdecken würde also bezirken der welt
lohnt sich ja noch nachmachen wir schon
fragt wo der schön brand wird es richtig
so könnt ihr auf den rückweg nach
amerika bekommt haben jetzt einfach auf
google eingeben muss zitierte tages
dürfte auf jeden fall geben wir jetzt
das ist okay nicht erschrecken das auto
vor mir bremst gerade deswegen ist
immerhin gesicht der richtig hunger
bekommen weil wir gestern doch so ein
bisschen aus streifen gegessen haben
hier nudeln mit sahnesoße und dann noch
wunderwaffe was ich aber nicht bereit
war super lecker geben jetzt die kräfte
ist und ich glaub ich auswärts immer so
die beste alternative wenn man gerade
auch deswegen so fertigen richtig lecker
natürlich es ist keine werbung
man muss ja immer echt angst haben dass
man die sachen dass die leute denken ja
die macht es da jetzt nur weil das ist
eben eine bezahlte kooperation ist echt
blöd im moment es ist übrigens gerade
erst kurz vor führen es aber schon
richtig dunkel draußen
wir hatten gerade unser gespräch mit dem
marketing team von kaufland so
sympathische menschen das besteck
einfach nur noch mehr dass ich kaufland
total liebe und was dann auf euch
zukommt bzw auf mich zukommt im nächsten
jahr das steht ihr dann aber wie ich
schon am anfang des blogs gesagt
überhaupt sich keine sorgen machen wir
werden niemals zu einer werbeplattform
ich habe zum beispiel auch das ist so
ein bisschen make ich habe ganz oft
anfragen bekommen wo ich mir dachte cool
davon kannst du dir jetzt schon einiges
leisten haben wir dann aber immer
gemerkt nie ganz echt sondern passt
nicht zu uns wir lehnen ab also und zwar
von anfang an wichtig dass wir uns nicht
hier für das schnelle geld verkaufen
also ihr müsst euch vorstellen meine
vision ist so wir ziehen gerade das
unternehmen k s kitchen auf was
vielleicht noch klein ist
irgendwann groß wir daran glaube ich
ganz fest und deshalb ist es immer so
wie man sich ein unternehmen aufbau
steckt man die ersten zwei bis drei
jahre ganz viel rein ob finanziell oder
vom fleiß ja man steckt einfach heraus
und so ist das einfach und dabei schon
gerne in den sauren apfel und wir machen
es ja auch total gerne das ist ja auch
alles machen ist mit liebe gemacht
ganz ehrlich haben sondern ich habe
schon gesagt wir machen das erste mal im
leben etwas das uns von herzen spaß
macht und ich finde es auch ganz toll
dass jedes zu schützen ist bekommen wir
auch mal ganz viel feedback das erste
schätzen ist das wie immer wir selbst
sind und uns nicht für irgendetwas
verkaufen und das wollen wir auch in
zukunft nichts machen auch in zukunft
nicht was wir hoffen ist einfach dass er
das merkt und das tut ihr bekomme ganzen
feedback dass er merkt dass wir uns nie
und nimmer für irgendwas verkaufen
würden oder dass wir irgendwann mal
dinge machen die einfach gar nicht zu
uns passen und einfach nur finanziell
erst bekam das passt nicht zu uns aber
es wäre schön wenn sich beides vereinen
lässt dass wir lange auf markt sind dass
wir lange auf youtube auf der plattform
sind und dann hat jeder was darüber
reden dass wir gerade einfacher schon im
stau stehen
straße mit dem mannheim nur damit die
kräfte ist kann mir mal bitte darüber
reden dass ich gestern
gestern wollte ich so gerne das ist auch
nötig
ich wollte eigentlich gäste haben will
war gestern nun ist nicht wollte so
gerne marokkanisch essen gehen weil ihr
mir das empfohlen habe
wir kennen angucken dann aber haben sie
wollte nicht hinzufahren wollten zu
bequem einfach um die ecke laufen und
dann da ist übrigens ist er gestern klar
geworden und so hochzeitsfeier ist in
knapp dreieinhalb monaten verdammt okay
wenn der block andern geht keine sun ist
es in drei monaten schon so weit ist
ding ist irgendwie ist der umzug und die
und youtube-videos diese ging so ein
bisschen im vordergrund wir müssen echt
aufpassen dass sich überhand nimmt und
dass wir uns wirklich zeit sich um alles
kümmern dass das wir schon haben ist der
saal und die bühnendeko wenn ihr euch
wundert was meint sie mit bühnendeko auf
einer hochzeit in der türkei zum
beispiel ist es auch gar nicht so dass
man extra noch dekorateur engagiert das
ist gar nicht so man nimmt den saal
sowie der ellipse ohne da haben sie ja
auch nicht haben sollten dass palästina
falls das möglich kostet und das ist
aber irgendwie so etabliert worden mit
der zeit und ich finde es richtig cool
ich war schon auf mehreren hochzeiten wo
ich gesehen habe dass die zahl noch mal
extra geschmückt wurde und ich finde es
macht so einen unterschied erst mal fürs
ambiente wenn man da ist wenn die gäste
da sind und natürlich auch für die fotos
für die videoaufnahmen das sieht einfach
so viel schöner aus und da habe ich
gesagt also da werde ich auf jeden fall
rein investieren die deko ist ganz ganz
wichtig was ich auch ganz wichtig ist es
musik oder musik läuft gar nichts
stimmung ist das a und o und da werde
ich eine dj engagieren dass man sich
absprechen kann und ich da die lieder
und sowas darüber schicken kann ist die
bescheid was welche lieder dann dran
kommen sollen was haben wir noch und die
torte spät bzw habe ich der privatparty
du kannst dich ruhig austoben ich
vertraue dir ich habe ihr die farben
gesagt das farbthema und sie wird nur
vorher aber zeigen wie die torte
aussehen wie das ist eine ganze
überraschung jetzt nicht aber ich lass
dir da auf jeden fall richtig viel
freiraum weil ich sehr vertraue die
dekoration übernimmt übrigens durch
einen effektiven junis das hat deshalb
ihr empfohlen also da bin ich auch sehr
dankbar wenn ich irgendwelche fragen hat
uns ganz genau auf instagram wenn ich
irgendwelche fragen gehabt dann mache
ich meine story und dann kommt ihr mit
vorschläge und ich glaube sollte effekt
wurde mir zu 80 vorgeschlagen weil ich
auch froh dass es für mich zeit hatte
direkt war richtig gut aber ihr leben
das wichtigste fehlt mein brautkleid ich
habe keins ich habe keine forschung
design soll 000 ich weiß auch gar nicht
wann ich irgendwie kennt ihr das man
denke ja und irgendwie sieht man dass
die ganze zeit auf war irgendwie es doch
schon alles eng mit der zeit übrigens im
ersten block da kam einige kommentare
was ich auch verstehen kann weil nicht
alle folgen uns auf instagram nicht
alles informiert kehrte gefragt haben
seid ihr nicht verheiratet und vor allem
warum wartet ihren fünf monate zusammen
zieht dazu muss ich noch einmal ganz
kurz ein paar aufklärende sätze sagen
und zwar wir sind standesamtlich und
islamisch verheiratet aber ihr wisst ja
selber in unseren kulturkreisen feiert
man die hochzeit sehr groß das heißt mit
ungefähr 700 leuten und weil wir nicht
unseren eltern auf der tasche liegen
möchten haben wir das alles angespart
das heißt es da hat ja auch dass man
sich so ein bisschen das ganze geld
verdienen es kommt ja auch nicht von
heute auf morgen man hat ja auch
fixkosten dann habt ihr auch sachen die
man so jeden monat bezahlen muss man
will ja auch von ingersleben und
deswegen haben wir den termin so ein
bisschen weiter nach hinten verschoben
weil wir eben das ganze geld sparen muss
ist er ganz normal und die frage warum
wartet ihr fünf monate und bezahlt fünf
monate miete ihr zusammenziehen topf 3
das ist ganz einfach man muss sich die
wohnung ja auch einrichten da braucht
man ja auch ein bisschen vorlauf und ein
bisschen zeit man kann sich ja nicht
eine wohnung mieten und direkt nach
einer woche direkt einziehen also da
braucht man ja auch so ein bisschen zeit
also das nochmal so aufklären also falls
sich fragen kommt das bin ich auch
keinem übel
niemand kennt uns zu hundert prozent die
man verfolgt uns auf den plattformen und
weiß immer was sache ist also falls ihr
fragen habt immer immer gerne her damit
wenn sie nicht zu persönlich sind dann
beantworte ich die auch gerne manche
frauen sind wegen schon probiert auf der
matte wenn du hast du gar nicht zu dick
angezogen haben sagt auch bei hansa ein
flüssiger sagen ich bin immer noch
eifersüchtig auf dem pullover
danke
also ein herr tipp wenn ihr in
großstädten oder neun städten seite und
dann einfach mal vergessen würden wo er
parkt hat schickt euch einfach den
standort kann so schickt mir jetzt
nämlich den standort von hier vom
parkhaus p whatsapp und dann haben wir
nachher keine probleme wir wissen von
unseren plänen dass wir zum chicas wir
sitzen im restaurant
mit sondern für ungezügelten rudi
ziemlich für die fahrt mitgenommen die
bild ausfallen
[Musik]
lächeln zu kaufen
ja ich habe es im kasten und
klassenzimmer was die person dahinter
bitte was
in dem kaffeehaus gesehen worden
das drin lobt
aber nicht nur nicht ausschließlich
starten
ich bin
was ist zudem immer noch das habe ich
mir bestellt das sind der kippe dann gab
es noch tipps dabei jedoch keine
röllchen haben sie zur schau gestellt
und die preise sind absolut vertretbar
zu bezahlen nicht auch nicht mehr als
wenn sie jetzt im prozess
ich weiß nicht ob jetzt noch etwas
spannendes kommt deswegen verabschiede
ich mich jetzt einfach schon mal führen
ja ich bin sehr lustig aus ich weiter
weil sie so kalt ist ja auch muss ich
hoffe natürlich dass ich den blog
gefallen hat dass wir euch da so müsse
mitgenommen haben sich frankfurt und
heilbronn und mannheim
ich freue mich auf eure zahlreichen
kommentare ich lese gerne durch fragen
habt immer her damit oder wünsche für
den nächsten druck dann auch mit ihrem
herzen
[Musik]